bien sûr la départementalisation de
mayotte suppose beaucoup de
bouleversements
il va falloir entre autres mettre sur
pied une véritable administration un
commerce structure est aussi et trouver
ce qui ne sera pas facile dans
l'immédiat du travail pour tout le monde
oui moi emea bien que machete on en est
on il ya beaucoup de chômeurs il ya
beaucoup de sommeil
les gens espèrent qu'avec avec l'avancé
avec chef solution ça va aller mieux
parce que la france n'est pas mauvais
c'est comme ça et on trouvera des
débouchés pour nos pauvres secours plus
de la moitié de la population paysanne
vit de l'agriculture
l'agriculture c'est vrai c'est l'avenir
pour mayotte
mais la france et les responsables de
lille ou bien d'autres projets bien
d'autres idées
mais faut-il les civic nous attendions
surtout de la france qu'elle nous garde
au sein de la république pour préserver
nos libertés c'était ça l'objectif
fondamental you want a aurait ensuite
accessoirement si la france veut bien
apporter à cette population que de
bien-être nous ne voulons pas plus un
peu ou beaucoup parce qu'il faut faire
beaucoup de choses ici il faut pas trop
faire non plus à mon avis il ne faut pas
chercher à transformer trop profondément
le mode de vie des habitants il faut se
cantonner dans une mesure raisonnable
vous ne craignez pas que tout ce qui
fait le particularisme des mahorais
disparaissent avec l'arrivée de la
civilisation occidentale
la présidente m'a apporté le progrès
mais préservé l'essentiel de nos
coutumes et de notre vie nous voulons
être français mais aussi rester mans
mayotte en effet voulu rester française
et la france comme ne le dit pas la
chanson ne pouvait bon gré mal gré la
laisser tomber à elle bien sûr
maintenant d'assurer à ses lointains
enfants un niveau de vie décent et les
moyens du progrès à eux de préserver
leur identité leur tranquillité et au
fond leur équilibre
à eux de ne pas se laisser griser par le
miroir aux alouettes de la civilisation
moderne que les premiers accents du bal
du samedi soir avec la légion annonce
déjà
la civilisation le progrès peut être
demain oui alors que mayotte s'endort
paisiblement avec ses rêves ville
tranquille au milieu d'un océan qui se
voudrait de paix mais peut-être pas pour
très longtemps
l'atmosphère ce soir est nettement plus
détendu à beyrouth vous savez que la
chambre des députés a voté ce matin un
amendement à la constitution libanaise
permettant d'une façon maintenant
parfaitement légale l'élection d'un
nouveau président de la république cette
élection étant d'ailleurs le premier
acte d'une réforme en profondeur des
institutions libanaises cependant il
reste à convaincre l'actuel président
monsieur frangié de démissionner pour
réunir les députés libanais il a fallu
mobiliser plus de lui soldat qui depuis
trois jours en terre club de quartier
devait se tenir la réunion 30 blindés
étaient chargés de défendre les
parlementaires contre l'action des mises
les attentats ou les francs tireurs
comme le siège du parlement a été
bombardé et destitué en pleine zone de
combat les partis politiques
après quinze jours de véritables
négociations avaient finalement accepté
de tenir la réunion des députés
dans cette véritable zone tampon c'est
par les combattants chrétiens les
palestiniens à parlementaire avec dalida
à leurs disques pour la modique somme de
150 nouveaux francs à tout moment
l'entrée de la villa aurait pu être
transformé en véritable champ de
bataille car toute limitée avec le doigt
sur la gâchette et ce soir le liban
reste leader finalement un seul coup de
feu a été tiré pendant la réunion
c'est un record
cet homme seul est le favori logique de
paris roubaix c'est freddy maertens
mais il sait ce soir qu'il ya entre lui
et la victoire de nom eddy merckx et
roger de vlaeminck ces deux hommes ont
le même double objectif d'abord être le
premier à remporter quatre fois
paris-roubaix et ensuite de toute façon
empêché freddy maertens de gagner la
course entre les trois hommes
est ce vraiment la guerre logger nohl je
pense que c'est la guerre pendant la
course mais en haut du coup je parlais
ce froid mais pendant la course et
chacun poussoir moi je veux gagner les
deux jours devait gagner aussi alors je
pense que c'est normal c'est là la
rivalité c'est la course mais c'est pas
la grande amitié quand même non surtout
pas quand on fait la guerre pendant la
course et quand même pas la grande
invitée en hausse de course non plus
mais quand on voit dans la rue quelque
chose comme ça on parle quand même on ne
passe pas sans rien dire ou quelque
chose comme ça alors qu'est ce qui se
passe finalement on veut pas de vous
gagnez on veut pas que vous deveniez
populaire peut-être que ça moi je bats
pour gagner des couches et les deux
autres aussi mais ils sont déjà quelques
années beaucoup plus loin que moi alors
je veux y arriver aussi
ou essayer diaries d'y arriver ils
veulent m'empêcher je vais faire tout
mon possible pour y arriver
finalement c'est la loi de la jungle
c'est un peu la vie de tous les jours
oui on est quand même correct
professionnelle est en cours pour gagner
de l'argent on fait pas pour le sport
tout à fait plus peur de dire donc ça
rejoint l'impression qu'on a qu ils sont
deux à se partager depuis quelques
années le gâteau belge en l'occurrence
mr c'est de vlaeminck et qui ne veulent
pas qu'un troisième viennent prendre une
part oui c'est surtout ça
mais cela veut dire que tout le monde
s'en va en même temps quitte sa ville
l'abandonnent ça vous rappelle quelque
chose j'en suis certain à l'été dernier
et ça vous dit quelque chose l'été
prochain car en fait l'étalement des
vacances en france n'a jamais été
réussie et rien ne permet de dire qu'il
sera réussi cette année car regardez
votre calendrier
le 31 juillet c'est un samedi
vous imaginez la cohorte la foule sur
les routes
il n'ya qu'un français sur deux qui part
en vacances je sais bien mais ça fait ça
fait 25 26 millions d'habitants qui ont
décidé de prendre leurs vacances entre
le 15 juillet et le début septembre
alors chaque année on se pose les mêmes
questions pourquoi les vacances
scolaires sont elles à la même date
pourquoi bien qu'on coupe en zone
faut-il que les enfants soient tous sur
les mêmes plages en même temps pourquoi
les entreprises industrielles ne ferme
telle pas des dates séparer pourquoi
n'at-on pas plus d'idées c'est pourquoi
cette opération clé sous la porte à
epernay qui va consister à symboliser en
quelque sorte le départ simultané de la
moitié d'une population au même moment
devrait essayer de sensibiliser
l'opinion
réussira-t-elle à faire adopter des
mesures à apporter des solutions dès
cette année disons le franchement c'est
bien douteux mais si on en parle dès le
mois d'avril dès le 11 dès demain si on
réalise encore une fois dès le 31
juillet ce samedi qui sera sans doute
infernal que ça ne peut pas durer comme
ça peut être au niveau gouvernemental
patronales et de l'éducation nationale
voudra-t-on des solutions pour l'année
prochaine
qui atteint finalement dans tous ces
jeux de fruits dont l'argument de vente
comme un tourne autour du mot naturel
avec renfort de photos de jus de fruits
il faut oublier les éléments que l'on a
retiré ce que l'on ajoute les uns pour
garder le goût et les autres pour en
créer mais j'arrivais à compenser bac
d'abord je voudrais pas dire trop de mal
des déchets d'un fruit parce que de
toute façon dans un café il vaut mieux
boire un jus de fruits qu'à l'apéritif
ça c'est la première chose commence à se
présenter jus de fruits se présente sous
deux formes
d'abord sous la forme de concentrés
alors là qu'est ce qui se passe
eh bien on chauffe sous vide pour
éliminer bien sur l'eau de constitution
du fruit de orange par exemple
et puis on réduit ont réduit en général
à un cinquième c'est à dire quand vous
vendre une petite boîte en carton qui
fait 20 centilitres vous mettez ça dans
une bouteille d'un litre vous remplissez
avec 80 centimes litre d'eau et vous
obtenez à nouveau un litre de jus de
fruits du robinet ce n'est pas notre
composition des fruits première vue
c'est pas la même chose donc l'eau du
robinet ne remplacera jamais l'eau de
constitution du fruit donc cette façon
là pour moi je les limites
cet angle c'est que très souvent on
réduit sur place dans le pays de
production ce jus de fruits sous cette
forme là et puis on la mène donc plus
facilement en france et là à nouveau le
met dans des bouteilles dans les grands
de bouteilles et puis angoulvant sous la
forme de jus de fruits a marqué sur la
bouteille c'est obligatoire à base de
concentré mais c'est très souvent écrit
en tout petit bon ça c'est un point
épineux maintenant le judo freely même
le jus de fruits attention de jus de
fruits je vais pas en dire beaucoup de
mal parce que il ya une union qui
s'appelle l'union nationale des
producteurs distributeurs de jus de
fruits de métropole et d'outre-mer qui a
fait beaucoup de bien ce qui m'ennuie
c'est que cette union a déposé une
marque qui s'appelle 100% jus de fruits
la voilà on va d'ailleurs vous la
montrer mieux que ça s'il vous plaît on
ne veut pas nous la montrer dans c'est
pas grave
et alors un set cette marque ce sigle
est mis à la disposition de tous les
producteurs distributeurs de jus de
fruits qu'ils se conforment à la
réglementation en vigueur et aux
dispositions du présent règlement or
quelle est la réglementation du journal
officiel des communautés européennes il
est tout récent il est du 1er décembre
qui 60 alors là je vous lis c'est un peu
long mais c'est intéressant quand même
c'est très intéressant
seuls sont autorisés pour la fabrication
des jus de fruits le traitement au moyen
des substances suivantes et là ça
commence
l'acide l ascorbique 1 300 à la dose
nécessaire à l'effet anti oxygène moi je
ne connais pas cette dose d'oxygène la
zot lé anhydrite carbonique e 290 les
enzymes politique les enzymes pente et
holistique les enzymes là je peux pas
lire la gélatine alimentaire le tanin 20
tonite gel de 6,25 de signis kaolin
charbon adjuvant de filtration inerte
perlite amiante diato mythe la cellulose
polyamide insoluble plus un peu de sucre
parce que si par hasard bien il n'est
pas assez sucré on a le droit d'en
rajouter 1 alors le problème est là le
problème est là le problème est grave en
fait si vous voulez on fait à l'heure
actuelle des études sur l'accumulation
de ces produits sur l'organisme humain
ce sont des produits antiparasitaires on
en retrouve dans les tissus adipeux au
niveau des reins des êtres humains donc
ils ne sont pas totalement éliminé
dangereux pas dangereux c'est un pari
sur l'avenir
nous on est trop vieux déjà mais c'est
un pari sur l'avenir de nos enfants
alors moi vous savez ce que je fais mais
chez moi tranquillement
j'achète des fruits je les presse et
c'est parfait comme ça je vous le répète
encore une fois si vous êtes obligé de
le faire au café alcool à aa
prenez un jus de fruit plutôt qu'à
l'apéritif merci pour terminer à un coup
d'oeil sur la carte météo c'est assez
sympathique le du beau temps sur la plus
grande partie de la france demain
à noter cependant des formations
nuageuses en fin d'après midi sur
l'ouest de la france il sera encore
frais aux petites heures dans la journée
la température ce sera à peu près la
même que celle de cet après midi je me
ferai un plaisir de vous présenter la
dernière édition du journal vers 23h30
en attendant avec l'équipe de rédaction
d'un texte que je vous souhaite une
bonne soirée